[Aplausos]
vengo a hablar sobre el arte de
aparecerse es un
título qué
que cambiamos a última hora pero ahorita
van a ver por qué no
y yo de niño
pueden entender un poco de mi presente
por esa foto yo de niño crecí en un
ámbito de artistas no mis padres se
dedicaban a
a imprimir sellos con acuarela los
ilustraba mi mamá
los
los sacaban a la venta después de
imprimirlos le ponían un polvo de
realzado que no sé si ustedes han visto
las tarjetas de presentación que luego
tienen como un pequeño relieve esas ese
relieve en las tarjetas de presentación
está hecho con un polvo especial de
realizado no entonces así hacían estas
piezas mis papás
lo sacaban a la venta en la calle los
vendían en fiestas mexicanas de hoteles
en san josé del cabo en la calle
mi papá les decía a los extranjeros
cuando los vendía s disease and original
así que les decía
era una palabra así que vendía mucho
pues
cuando yo me voy de la ciudad de la paz
a estudiar
xalapa veracruz a la universidad
veracruzana me decido a estudiar artes
plásticas y empiezo a yo fui a estudiar
pintura pero como crecí en un ámbito de
sellos y estampación y un tallercito un
pequeño estudio cuando conozco la
técnica del grabado y de la impresión de
técnicas pues tan tradicionales que aquí
hay en méxico que es el grabado
como que me familiarizó y digo esto es
lo mío yo crecí en eso la stampa
pero entró en la carrera y empiezo a
escuchar la técnica del aceite zinc en
español el grabado al ácido y descubro
que no era como lo hacía en mi familia
entonces agarré le llamo a mi papá desde
xalapa veracruz y le digo que mentiroso
eres le vendía a los extranjeros otra
cosa que no era la verdadera técnica del
grabado el ácido pero bueno al fin y al
cabo eso me formó a mí como como creador
como artista y el arte me ha dado muchas
herramientas en la vida me ha dado las
mejores experiencias de mi vida los
viajes de mi vida y pues es una forma de
vivir increíble que se me ha dado
gracias a que crecí con una familia de
artistas
y pues estoy totalmente agradecido con
la vida y quiero exponerles un poco de
mi historia pero al mismo tiempo quiero
hablar de nuestra historia que es la
temática de estas
este télex no nuestra historia y quiero
que esto sirva como ejemplo no nomás en
nuestra sociedad para seña o de baja
california sur quiero que se siga sirva
como ejemplo para otras sociedades otras
comunidades que pueden voltear a ver al
arte
oa los hijos de su ciudad y que han
hecho
una que han sembrado pues una cultura y
una identidad en esas comunidades yo voy
a hablar de la historia del arte en baja
california sur en siglo al principio voy
a hablar un poco del siglo 18 eso es un
periódico que se llama 'el se llamaba el
diario de la paz de 1894 1893 de
extrañarse es que no haya un teatro en
la paz este recinto todavía no se
construye recuerden que en 1910 cuando
se construyó ese recinto
no había un teatro en la paz pero no
dejan de visitarla buenas compañías con
frecuencia que dejan ver y apreciar a la
sociedad del lugar los progresos y las
mejores producciones ojo de arte moderno
aunque con bastante dificultad por parte
del local yo leí esto estando en xalapa
veracruz a punto de terminar mi carrera
iba a ser una tesis sobre la las artes
gráficas del estado
y leer estas publicaciones leer ver
imágenes de aquella época dije claro que
había algo muy importante culturalmente
en esas épocas en la época del
porfiriato en el estado
fuimos una de las primeras zonas con una
comunidad que tenía electricidad eran
cinco apenas más o menos en todo el país
que tenían electricidad comunidades en
santa rosalía y existía una planta de
luz eso quiere decir que había un
progreso prometedor en el estado no que
iba a la par de la cultura y las artes
en una de mis viajes yo regresé de
república checa una vez
praga fui exponer y a visitar talleres
en república checa
conocí talleres de gran calidad desde la
litografía que el tradicional que se
hace en piedra si no conocen la técnica
igual se los dejo de tareas
conocí estos talleres y regresé a los
talleres de europa
alzado yo pero yo regresando tenía que
regresar a la ciudad de aguascalientes a
la inauguración del taller nacional de
gráfica que era invitado por la parte
del noroeste a dar una demostración de
una técnica que yo venía regresando
república checa parís parís méxico y a
las 4 tenía que ser el aeropuerto para
volar
aguascalientes con un jet la corrí bleu
y el demo así como que todo sueco pero
ahí estaban alas
4 de la tarde en el aeropuerto me tocó a
un maestro que se llama gabriel macotela
lo conozco este iba viajando con él
llegó al taller y me sorprendo del
taller no era un galerón gigantesco
donde construían los ferrocarriles en
mexico
[Música]
todo el taller era con la mejor calidad
de equipo para la producción artística
había un museo de sitio está una escuela
de artes todo lo iban a inaugurar el
taller de gráfica y se iba a inaugurar
el día siguiente de mi demostración
guadalupe posada todos los conocen por
la catrina ahora ya viene de día de
muertos
y esta imagen de la catrina la conocemos
desde no sé desde que tenemos memoria
la catrina ha dado la vuelta en el mundo
y es un grabado exactamente eso es un
grabado en la técnica de 5 grafía
guadalupe pasada posada nació en la
ciudad de aguascalientes
aguascalientes tiene afuera del taller
de gráfica nacional
una escultura gigantesca de posadas y
grandotes como la paloma que tenemos acá
en el marco pero más alto todavía y
para mí era como la tierra de posada
pues toda la vida estuve viendo libros y
obra de él pues
me invitaron al museo de posada en
aguascalientes en una visita guiada a
solas en la noche vi sus placas su
prensa todo lo que lo que se rescató de
de guadalupe posada
para mí eso me prendió el foco de algo
muy interesante mientras guadalupe
posada en la ciudad de méxico porque me
justo decir que posada la mayoría de su
obra la hace en la ciudad de méxico fue
descubierto en la ciudad de mexico de
aguascalientes viajan a méxico y lo
descubre diego ribera es el que más
levanta el nombre de guadalupe posada
entonces
se formó en la ciudad de mexico
totalmente entonces en 1893 mientras
posada estaba haciendo eso en la ciudad
de mexico que estaba pasando aquí pues
en baja california sur ojo en torno a mi
rubro no el arte yo no me meto otros
rubros pero el mío si me interesaba
entonces que estaba pasando pues
conocen esa imagen lo han visto si
pasamos ahorita por la que hay
independencia a la catedral van a
reconocer ese edificio no es la logia de
los masones es una de las logias más
antiguas del país y es un grabado
impresionantemente para mí ver un
grabado de esa época en el que la paz
fue fue como que existe un grabador
contemporáneo a guadalupe posada en mi
tierra y eso me despertó un interés
hermoso por por la investigación de la
gráfica en mi estado natal esos grabados
son de un personaje llamado adrian
valadez castro
adrián valadés castro no fue simplemente
un grabador como posada él fue inclusive
un trabajador del ayuntamiento fue
tesorero fue secretario fue recopilador
de historias y de ir de toda la historia
de baja california sur en la
colonización le rescató él fue un
personajazo y fue un personaje que se le
dedicó mucho amor a estas tierras porque
mencionó eso pues porque a adrián
valadez tiene una cepa de familiares
artistas aquí pueden ver la tradicional
vestimenta de la cuerno del ranchero que
pocas veces la vemos ilustrado de esta
manera son grabados de 1800 pero el
rollo traer si ahorita es un rollo traer
materiales para trabajar acá y mandarlos
a traer el proveedor y que si le
llamamos por teléfono el barco y todos
en ese tiempo
era más canijo el barco tardaba
muchísimo y el material del grabado es
complejo la verdad entonces adriano a la
vez tuvo un nieto
llamado edmundo valadés hijo de adrián
odilón valadés que nació aquí en la paz
se fue a guaymas tuvo a su hijo a
edmundo valadés
el premio
el premio latinoamericano de cuento
lleve el nombre del mundo valores
bibliotecas kinders este gran jardín de
niños pues
1981 el premio de periodismo lleva y se
lo llevó edmundo valadés el creador de
un género literario creador de un género
literario la microficción el cuento el
cuento corto el mundo valores
porque mencionó esto pues
aguascalientes a pesar de que
guadalupe posada no
o se formó en la ciudad de
aguascalientes y se formó en la ciudad
de méxico su taller lo tenía en la
ciudad de méxico en la ciudad de méxico
donde está el taller de posada hay sólo
dos placas de los aniversarios de
nacimiento y aniversario luctuoso de
posada pero hasta ahí la tea el local es
una tienda de plásticos no es más que
eso lo conocemos por la catrina y es las
calaveras son el 20 por ciento de su
obra tiene mucha obra pero
aguascalientes se ha aprovechado mucho
de su hijo del hijo de la ciudad es un
cuadro que ha gustado el museo las
esculturas
día de muertos es un festival gigantesco
que hacen allá gente de todos lados
y aguascalientes no tienen las bellezas
naturales que tenemos nosotros aquí pero
han sido muy inteligentes y es un
ejemplo que estoy dando para vuelvo a
repetir para otras comunidades no de la
de la cultura del turismo cultural el
turismo cultural es un turismo que puede
funcionar muy bien en este estado
y unos y unos décimos
es que cultura identidad casi no hay las
pinturas rupestres y de repente hay un
vacío en las artes plásticas hasta
ahorita otra generación pero no tenemos
un chorro de personajes y eso es un
ejemplo de ellos yo quise hacer esta
plática en honor a estos artistas porque
llevamos esa tierra y amo lo que hago
también
otro otro personaje que me
que me inspiró toda mi carrera mi
licenciatura
fue el maestro carlos olachea
carlos olachea es nacido en santa
rosalía
es parte de una generación muy
importante de artistas salidos de aquí
del estado que estudiaron en la ciudad
de mexico
carlos olachea llegó a ser catedrático
de la escuela nacional de artes
plásticas fue becado por el gobierno
francés estudió en francia regrese a
méxico
hay un taller ahorita de producción
gráfica que lleva el nombre de carlos
olachea en la ciudad de mexico
y aquí conocemos la galería carlos
olachea lleva el nombre de él pero es
muy poco lo que tenemos sobre su obra
pues sobre su historia y mi generación
la mayoría de mi generación no conoce la
obra de carlos olachea y a mí me duele
eso porque
a mí eso fue lo que me motivó si yo si
yo hubiera crecido antes de irme a
xalapa si hubiera crecido viendo la obra
de esos maestros y en una sala y hubiera
conocido estos personajes y hubiera ido
con otro discurso totalmente el interior
del país
pero no fue así yo los conocí después y
bueno las cosas sean así y aquí ya
tenemos el museo carrillo gil obra de
carlos olachea que nos está
representando allá en el museo de
carrillo gil y tristemente también
tenemos subastas en línea que venden la
obra de carlos olachea
subastas que están
vendiendo a la cultura y la historia de
las artes del estado
en línea no puede entrar a abrir cuenta
y si tiene dinero comprar la historia
eso es un poco sorprendente pero fue un
poco sorprendente toparme con esto pero
bueno
aquí en estas ponencias se nos pide
hacer una invitación pues para accionar
nos para
ser ser darle continuidad a estos
discursos a estas pláticas
y guadalupe posada muere en la ciudad de
mexico por cirrosis era muy pobre lo
llevan al panteón de dolores lo
entierran en una tumba de tercera clase
a los años el dueño del terreno del
panteón lo saca del sacan los cuerpos
que estaban en esa parte de las tumbas
baratas y lo lleva a una fosa común los
restos de guadalupe posada están
perdidos no se saben dónde están y la
historia de sus restos se perdieron pero
se rescataron pues sus obras y su prensa
su imprenta 6 un museo que tiene un
taller se le dio este valor y ahorita lo
conocemos todos por medio de la imagen
de la catrina
carlos olachea
ghana segundo lugar en la bienal rufino
tamayo en la ciudad de oaxaca
oaxaca igual la mezcla llega a su casa
con el mezcal seca y sobre una lámpara
de cristal se desangra no cobra ni el
cheque la bienal y ahí queda
esta foto es tomada en su estudio y es
mi última diapositiva es tomada por el
maestro nivel ángulo
y
estas historias que les cuento pues yo
les va a ser sincero le había puesto el
arte de desaparecer a la ponencia a la
plática porque pues estos artistas
fueron desapareciendo pues su obra
desapareció durante un tiempo posadas de
precio de un durante mucho tiempo pues
pero más que eso fuimos más positivos
aquí en ted y me dijeron el arte de
reaparecer y eso es lo que tenemos que
hacer pues
está en cada uno si nos dedicamos en el
arte al arte a la cultura o no nos
dediquemos totalmente si lo apreciamos o
no lo apreciamos pero creo y siento pues
que investigar en torno a una en una
identidad cultural en el estado si
podemos rescatar cada quien con un
granito de arena la la la historia de la
tierra donde vivimos ensalzar la apoyar
proyectos independientes apoyar
proyectos grandes que se estén haciendo
en el estado en torno a la cultura
siempre es bien valioso porque si
podemos producir una gestión de turismo
cultural en baja california sur vamos a
hacer como han dicho mis compañeros la
mejor ciudad del mundo tenemos todo en
otras ciudades las ballenas no vienen a
visitarlos en otras ciudades no tienen
un tiburón ballena que está en la bahía
en otras ciudades no tienen estos
paisajes que tenemos con el cierre la
laguna la sierra de la giganta la sierra
de guadalupe
todos estos paisajes hermosos que
estamos privilegia decimos pues ahora
sumarle un turismo cultural y una
historia cultural una identidad vamos a
hacer la mejor ciudad del mundo y espero
que les haya gustado mi plática muchas
gracias por asistir
[Aplausos]